okay lesson thirteen point two we're
going to talk about trigonometric
identities and what exactly are
trigonometric identities well identity
means that it's a identical meaning it's
one quantity that's identical to another
quantity and these are all the different
ones that we're going to be working with
in this lesson and what you can do is
add this to your note sheets and I want
to show you first before we jump into
some example problems just like where
some of these identities come from so we
talked about the unit circle in an
earlier lesson how it's a circle with
radius one and you can construct a
triangle like this where if you locate
at any point on the unit circle you can
drop a perpendicular to the x-axis and
then you can see it forms this right
triangle where to get to this point
you're going right X up Y and the
hypotenuse is one this central angle
here we call theta that's the Greek
letter theta for the central angle this
angle over here is 90 minus theta these
two angles add up to 90 plus 90 gives us
180 for the triangle sum so these two
angles are always gonna be complementary
so these identities we talked about in a
earlier lesson just how cosecant in sign
our reciprocal secant and cosine are
reciprocals cotangent and tangent are
reciprocals so you already know those
you also know that sine is 1 over
cosecant cosine is 1 over secant and
tangent one of our cotangent so they're
just reciprocals of one another then
we've got tangent is equal to the sine
over cosine which you learn before but
because cotangent the reciprocal of
tangent we can think of cotangent as
being the cosign divided by the sine and
then so these ones are pretty familiar
with but then now the Pythagorean
identities these might be new to you we
know the Pythagorean theorem a squared
plus B squared equals C square but in
this case you can see x squared plus y
squared equals 1 squared or 1 but
remember how we said that the on the
unit circle that the cosine is the
x-coordinate so if we replace X with
cosine that's going to be cosine theta
squared and then the y-coordinate we
said was the sine of theta so that's the
sine of theta squared equals 1 now when
they write this they don't usually write
the quantity squared like that they'll
put the two by the cosine so cosine
squared theta that's the same as the
cosine theta the Kwan
squared plus sine squared theta equals 1
so this is your basic Pythagorean trig
identity that's when you want to
definitely memorize but if you were to
take all these values and divide them by
let's just say sine squared of theta
then what happens is cosine squared
divided by sine squared gives you
cotangent squared sine squared divided
by sine squared is 1 and 1 over sine
squared is cosecant squared so that's
how you get this third Pythagorean
identity and then if we were to divide
all these by instead of sine squared by
cosine squared so let's divide by cosine
squared now now cosine divided by cosine
squared is gonna give us 1 ok sine
squared divided by cosine squared is
tangent squared and 1 divided by cosine
squared is secant squared so just
remember that
C sine over cosine is tangent right but
if these are both squared then it's
gonna be tangent squared so those are
the three Pythagorean trig identities
now the cofunction ones you can see that
sine and cosine have grouped together
tangent and cotangent secant and
cosecant but when you see PI over 2
that's in radians but you can think of
it as a 90-degree angle so sine of 90
minus theta is the same as cosine of
theta one way to understand this is if
you go to this triangle here C sine of
this angle the 90 minus theta angle this
one here remember sine is the opposite
over hypotenuse so see how we're getting
X divided by one whereas the cosine of
theta is adjacent over hypotenuse see
how we're also getting x over one so the
sine of 90 minus theta is the same as
cosine and cosine of 90 minus theta is
the same as sine and it's the same thing
with tangent and cotangent secant and
cosecant now for the negative angles all
a negative angle means is that instead
of going counterclockwise that's
positive we're going clockwise that's
going to be a negative angle so we could
construct the same triangle that we have
here it's just that now this angles
going to be negative theta when you go
clockwise right to get to this point
we're going right X we're going down Y
so that's going to be negative Y so the
coordinates at this point are going to
be X comma negative Y so if you wanted
to find out what's the sine of negative
theta this angle it's going to be
opposite over hypotenuse
but you can see we're getting negative Y
over one so it's the same as a sign of
positive theta which is ops over
hypotenuse y over 1 the only difference
is is that you're multiplying by a
negative same thing here with cosine of
negative theta so if we do cosine of
this angle negative theta its adjacent
that's this side over hypotenuse that's
x over 1 if we do the cosine of positive
theta that's adjacent which is x over 1
so you can see that cosine of negative
theta is the same as cosine of positive
theta those are equal and then same
thing for the tangent of negative theta
tangent of this angle would be opposite
over adjacent so you're getting negative
Y over X if you do the tangent of
positive theta you're getting opposite
over adjacent you're getting positive Y
over X so we're getting that same ratio
Y over X is just that here it's negative
so you can see tangent of negative theta
is the same as tangent of positive theta
it's just multiplied by negative 1 so
let me erase this diagram here I've got
some introductory examples we're going
to go through and then we'll have some
problem that you can practice on your
own and get more experience with
simplifying trig identities want to
learn algebra to check out my learn
algebra 2 video course for sale where we
go through 85 video lessons that take
you step by step by step through algebra
2 we go through the important formulas
concepts as well as numerous examples to
help you master algebra to click the
interactive card or the link in the
description below to go over and check
out some of the free lessons otherwise
let's get back into this current lesson
ok in these first three examples a B and
C what we're doing we're going to
simplify these expressions as much as we
can we're going to try to condense them
down using our identities you remember
identities they're identical so they're
equal we can swap one quantity for
another so let's look at example a here
we've got cosine x times tangent X well
we know that tangent is sine over cosine
so this is going to be sine of X divided
by cosine of X times cosine of X which
cosine of X is like cosine of X over 1
so you can always put something over 1
if you want to write it as a fraction
notice that cosines are canceling
numerator and denominator so we just
have sine of X divided by 1 which equals
sine of X and that's as far as we can
simplify that down ok let's go to
example B now we've got secant theta
times cosine theta times tangent squared
theta
so what we're gonna do now is we know
secant is really the reciprocal of
cosine it's one over cosine cosine of
theta is really just itself right or you
could put it over 1 + tangent squared
theta is actually sine squared theta
over cosine squared theta
see how tangent sine over cosine but if
this is squared both of these are going
to be squared so now what we can do is
we can reduce we can see that this
cosine cancels with this cosine and we
just have sine squared over cosine
squared which really is just tangent
squared so that one there wasn't too
much to that one let's go to an example
see now we've got sine squared divided
by tangent squared so sine squared is
really just sine squared tangent squared
is sine squared divided by cosine
squared but remember when you divide by
a fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so this is going to be sine
squared over one you put anything over
one divided by which is like multiplying
by the reciprocal cosine squared X over
sine squared X so notice those are
canceling numerator and denominator so
we're just left with cosine squared of X
now the last two introductory examples I
want to show you D&E these are called
verifying so here they're actually
telling us what the answer is you know
what it actually simplifies down to it's
just up to us to show step by step that
the left side is identical to the right
side or vice versa but normally what I
do is I work with the more expanded side
the sine that's like larger and I try to
condense it down to the smaller side so
for letter D here cosine of X we know is
just cosine of X secant of X we know is
1 over cosine of X cosine is like cosine
over 1 these are going to cancel we have
1 over 1 which is 1 so you can see 1
equals 1 and you you've shown it proved
it or verified it for letter E now this
one's a little bit more challenging we
can see the left side is more expanded I
would work with the side first and try
to show it equals cosecant squared
secant squared minus tangent squared
whenever I'll give you a hint whenever I
see the ones with the squares I often
think of the three Pythagorean trig
identities it's not all the time but
often times it'll be one of these so
secant squared minus tangent squared
notice here if I subtract tangent
squared from both sides of this equation
you would get one equals secant squared
minus tangent squared so that's
numerator here is actually equal to one
with this one one minus cosine squared
see if I subtract the cosine squared
over two this right side sine squared
equals one minus cosine squared so this
is going to be sine squared and we know
that the reciprocal of sine is cosecant
and the reciprocal of cosecant is sign
they're reciprocals but because this is
squared this is going to be equal to
cosecant squared and you can see we've
got a match and we verified or proved it
so you just want to take it step by step
as long as you're replacing one
equivalent quantity with another then
you know you're going to get there
eventually it just might take an extra
step or two but again you know just work
with the more Spanish side condense it
to a more condensed side so let me erase
the whiteboard I've got some examples
I'd like for you to practice to get some
more experience and we'll do those next
okay here's your opportunity to practice
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can do some of these problems on your
own and we'll go through them together
so the first three examples what we're
gonna do is we're gonna simplify the
expression as much as we can so for
number one we've got sine of PI over 2
minus theta all over cosine theta what
does that condense down to how would you
do that one well let's see we've got PI
over 2 minus theta these are our KO
functions sine of PI over 2 minus theta
equals cosine theta so this is just
going to be cosine theta over cosine
theta anything divided by itself is 1 so
you've got it ok let's try number two
now so you can do this one cosine of
negative x divided by sine of negative x
so here you can see we're working with a
negative angle how would you do that one
well if we go to our negative angle
identities here we've got sine of
negative theta equals the opposite of
sine of theta and cosine of negative
theta equals the same as cosine theta so
we've got let's see cosine of negative X
would just be the same as cosine of X
sine of negative x is negative sine of X
and cosine divided by sine we know is
cotangent but a positive divided by a
negative is a negative so this is a
negative cotangent of X and you've got
it so let's look at number three now
we've got 1 minus cosine squared of X
over cosine squared of X how would you
do that one well you can see we've got
some squares here so I'm going to look
at the Pythagorean identities here we
can see 1 minus cosine squared 1
subtract cosine squared that would equal
sine squared as long as you do the same
thing to both sides of these equations
it's going to be equivalent so 1 minus
cosine squared we have is sine squared X
over cosine squared X sine divided by
cosine we know is tangent but since
these are both squared that's going to
be tangent squared of X and you've got
it ok so now let's go to number 4 & 5 &
6 and we're gonna verify these
identities so we've got cotangent x
times secant x times sine of x equals 1
how would you verify that the left side
and the right side are equivalent okay
if I was going to do this problem
I know cotangent is cosine over sine
secant we know is 1 over cosine and sine
you can just write as sine over 1
because anything divided other one is
itself the cosines cancel numerator
denominator the signs cancel numerator
and denominator so we have 1 over 1
which is 1 equals 1 and we verified or
proved it ok let's go to number 5 now
how would you do this 1 3 minus sine
squared X equals 2 plus cosine squared X
how would you do that 1 well let's see
we've got some squares in here so let's
see if we can look at some of these
Pythagorean trig identities sine squared
is equal to 1 minus cosine squared so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say 3 minus but instead of sine squared
we're going to put what sine squared
equals which is 1 minus cosine squared
we're gonna leave the right side just as
it is okay
so we're just going to work with one
side here now the negative I can
distribute the negative into the
parenthesis that's going to be 3 minus 1
negative times a negative is positive
cosine squared X so now we've got 3
minus 1 is equal to 2 plus cosine square
root of X and you can see we've got a
match
so we verified it okay number 6 a little
bit more challenging one see if you can
do this one we've got 1 plus sine of X
divided by cosine X plus cosine X over 1
plus
Sinex we're trying to show that equals
to seek an X so how would you do that
problem well if I was going to do it I
would notice that there's like one group
here but there's like two groups here so
we're gonna have to combine these
somehow and because they have different
denominators we have to find that common
denominator so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to multiply this fraction here
by what it's missing it's missing a one
plus sine of X but whatever you do to
the denominator you have to do to the
numerator so that's going to give us
that fraction over here we're missing a
cosine X I'm going to multiply the
denominator here by cosine X I'm going
to multiply the numerator by cosine X
anything divided by itself is 1 so I
won't change the overall value it's just
gonna change the way that looks so we've
gotten I always got we have 1 plus sine
x times cosine X we're just gonna leave
that in factored form ok
here I'm going to foil this out so 1
times 1 is 1 1 times sine X is sine X
sine X times 1 is sine X so we're
getting 2 sine X sine X times sine X is
sine squared X and then over here we've
got cosine times cosine which is cosine
squared X over the same denominator so
I'm just going to add these two
fractions together keep that common
denominator but now look what we have
here we've got sine squared plus cosine
squared if we add that together we get 1
C sine square plus cosine squared equals
1 so 1 plus 1 gives us 2 plus 2 sine X
all over 1 plus sine X cosine X but you
see here we can factor out a 2 so let's
do that that's going to be 1 plus sine x
times 2 and if you notice in the
numerator in the denominator the 1 plus
sine X is going to cancel with this 1
plus sine X so we have 2 over cosine X
which remember the reciprocal of cosine
is secant ok so you can see this is
actually working out to 2 secant X which
is what we were trying to prove that it
was equal to and you verified it so
great job add these formulas to your
note sheet so you can work on memorizing
those and if you need to review this
lesson go ahead and do that
otherwise I'll see you in the next
lesson